femme honorable qui est la biographie de
biographies faut bien le dire
passionnante de marie curie
la première question c'est la somme de
documents vous avez dû chercher
oui il y en a beaucoup c'est
relativement facile de les trouver
la plupart sont à la bibliothèque
nationale il y en a aussi pas mal dans
les universités anglaises américaines
terra pour faire ce travail avec
beaucoup de plaisir parce que c'était
important
il m'a semblé que c'était important une
femme honorable est ce que c'est
vraiment l'appellation la meilleure pour
marie curie vous savez j'ai pensé à une
formule des écrivains paul valéry que
j'aime beaucoup et qui dit de deux maux
il faut toujours choisir le moindre
deux mots et motets et alors il y a bien
entendu une grande partie de ce livre
consacré à la rencontre avec pierre
curie la rencontre qui est venu en 1894
c'était le coup de foudre
il s'est passé tellement de choses dans
la vie de cette femme en face à sela
fait le plus connu dire c'est son
mariage avec pierre curie parce que
c'est une c'est une très belle histoire
d'une belle histoire d'amour
c'est une belle histoire parce que
c'était mais cette femme avec une très
grand respect l'un pour l'autre une très
haute idée de chacun de la valeur de
l'autre qu'ils se sont lavés écrasé
morales ayant tellement et moral est
excellent que pierre curie le fai a fait
à savoir une confiance est tout à fait
remarquable à l'époque ce n'est pas
tellement pour vous il a même mis en la
mettant même en avant ils la mettaient
qu'envoyer disait la vérité c'est à dire
que c'est elle qui a découvert de radio
vous contrairement à ce que dit encore
disent encore les grands dictionnaires
et lui le savez bien
il est venu travailler avec elle il a
abandonné provisoirement pensait-il ses
travaux personnels qui étaient tout à
fait remarquable et qui lui aurait valu
que ray du shaq mono disait que pierre
curie aurait dû avoir le prix nobel nuit
pour ces travaux qu'il avait rien à voir
avec leur à berne
il est venu l'argent
lorsqu'elle a dit la radioactivité c'est
le mot quel art qu'elle a inventé est le
résultat d'un phénomène qui se produit à
l'intérieur de l'atome et c'est un
nouvel élément qui produit ses effets
d'aubaine et il est venu parce que
c'était très excitant c'était de trouver
un nouvel élément
mais le travail c'est marie qui l'a fait
l'hypothèse c'était qu'il a posés et
c'est une personne extraordinaire mais
vous avez bien fait de me reprendre
quand je leur ai dit je vais parler du
couple que tout de suite c'est d'un
commun effectivement pas ce qui s'est
passé beaucoup de choses avant ses
abonnements elles étaient polonais je
crois elle était polonaise alors triode
polonaise est là aussi
elle est en quelque sorte dans
l'actualité parce que c'est une pologne
enfin je ne veux pas vous proposer des
problèmes politiques pollet qui à
l'époque est interne en occuper barr
virus et soudain plus que ceux des vi
nations
c'est un territoire russe alors elle est
révoltée elle fait partie de
l'université volant temps je passe sur
tous les événements d'un commun elle est
venu très tard en france elle est venue
à 24 ans alors l'avait elle a vécu une
vie de femme à une époque où c'était pas
une vie facile je crois que quelqu'un a
dit vous le décrivez dans votre livre il
y avait le choix entre être ménagères ou
courtisanes dont c'est le pari
syndicalisme alors pensez donc
ll a réussi à imposer sa vie de femme
telle qu'elle avait envie de la vie or
elle était tout à fait supérieure sur le
plan intellectuel enfin sur un plan
scientifique sans aucun doute mais il
était aussi ce qu'on peut être génial et
médiocre d'autre part elle était aussi
une personne tout à fait exceptionnelle
par son courage par son entêtement qui
est un entêtement très féminin est
d'ailleurs ses méthodes de travail
étaient des méthodes très féminine et
l'on tait
elle était en plus ça leur très très
séduisant dans le meilleur sens du terme
c'est à dire à la fois séduisante
intellectuellement par son intelligence
et parce qu'elle était belle elle était
surtout belle elle a été belle en dise
enfin il est délaissé boulot on a quand
même d'accord détenteurs cantal a connu
pierre curie mais oui c'est un couple
qui n'a vécu en fait qu'une dizaine
d'années ensemble vous êtes tenu de la
fin tragique de pierre curie l or on a
l'impression que la vie de mary kay
s'arrête ce jour là elle devient la
veuve illustre essai c'est pas du tout
le cas et c'est évidemment un épisode de
sa vie extraordinairement douloureux et
qu'il a beaucoup marqué mais ensuite
elle a eu elle-même un second prix nobel
seuls là et elle a joué un rôle tout à
fait considérable dans la science
française puisqu'elle a créé l'institut
du radium elle a accumulé la des
matières les plus précieux du monde l a
fait pour la science française une
action tout à fait considérable qui est
peu connu et je pensais que c'est
intéressant de la montre est elle sur le
fond historique de cette époque qui est
aussi très intéressant ces dernières
questions rendre le giro si marie curie
revenu aujourd'hui est-ce que le serai
s'inscrirait dans son temps trop les
tétons avant et encore on avance à
françois girault merci je vous avais dit
tout à l'heure que nous allions rappeler
la bourse alors les tendrons c'est à
vous nous vous rappelons et bien jean
claude narcy les choses